we got the tweet from Mark J Perry says
get woke go broke Target shares have
dropped by 15.3 percent in the last 11
days since the boycott started over
lgbtq friendly kids clothing
representing an eye-popping loss and its
market value of 11.4 billion the story
from Fox Business they say Target and
Bud Light investors lose billions on
marketing misses Target Anheuser-Busch
have lost a combined 28 billion dollars
in market value the target thing stands
out the most to me because this wasn't
look I understand the Dylan Mulvaney
thing domovenians a Domo Vanity's
audience are our children domovenia is
effectively just playing a character
like Borat or you know or um who was the
other character you played Bruno was at
it yeah that's one of them
that's basically what Dylan Mulvaney's
doing and when people see that they're
put off by it they're angered by it
they're insulted by it they say hey we
want an apology well it's also an adult
male playing the role of a little girl
yep which made it even more yeah that's
like Bruno that's like it's it's it's
it's right it's it disturbs people what
I've heard from many people is uh and
I'm not trying to be overtly derisive
but people have said disgust yes and so
what you know at first I was saying of
the Bud Light boycott that people just
don't want to be associated with an
effeminate beer then I will say like no
they actually they look at it with
disgust because it's Associated now I
can understand the boycott there's very
strong the emotions are very strong the
thing with Target is that this is just a
company doing their typical pride month
thing all of the companies are gonna
start putting the pride month stuff out
there
Target now losing billions
11.4 billion in market value for doing
what companies have done for some time
that marks a massive shift that's why I
think this story is so important because
typically these companies do this stuff
nobody bats an eye conservatives don't
do a thing but now we're experiencing a
Cascade in the uh an exponential gain in
what in the Bud Light effect that is yes
someone's here's how I described it
earlier
somebody's holding shares stock in
Target and Bud Light
let's say they got 100 of each
hypothetical number
they're told don't worry the Bud Light
thing will blow over boycotts never work
and they say okay and they're sitting on
63 per share now it's at 59 and they're
going dude I just lost like eight
percent because you told me to wait so
they sell that triggers the price going
down even more but they're also holding
Target stock let's just say type A
hypothetical number X and then the
controversy breaks they go no I am not
going to wait around and lose another 10
they sell now there is a fear in the
market being brewed doesn't matter if
you actually oppose wokeness it doesn't
matter if you support wokeness all that
matters is if a company gets woke their
stock will go down and that will create
a self-fulfilling prophecy and I think
what happened with the whole Bud Light
effect as you call it which is a great
term is it gave conservatives confidence
because we had zero reason to be
confident in any type of boycott I've
said for years we've got to pick one
company I've said this for probably 10
years we've got to pick one company
that's done something it's got to be
something we can live without we can
certainly live without horse urine I
don't want to get you a mark on YouTube
here
um we got to pick one company that we
can do without and go all in and cause
permanent economic damage until we cause
permanent economic harm to one of these
companies it'll keep happening we skip a
couple football games but we're back in
the stands three weeks later three games
later they don't give a crap they know
that all the conservatives will be back
they cave every time we'll have a blip
for three weeks if this sent the message
that oh wow these guys are sticking to
it they're angry and when people see the
effect of the Bud Light thing it's like
you said self-fulfilling now they're
wanting to recreate it they're they're
energized and they have a confidence
level of hey we can't actually do this
as conservatives like wow we do have
half the buying power take a look at
this story from New York mag
just asking questions is the is the
section Bud Light Target and a new era
of corporate caution by Benjamin Hart I
love this he says initially he thought
nothing would happen he says uh I
assumed it would have little to no
effect instead it has delivered a major
hit to Bud Light sales he then goes on
to say why do you uh he says uh do you
think okay let me start over how unusual
is it for a campaign to be working this
well and do you think those factors are
why it's been so successful ladies and
gentlemen Pat yourselves in the back I
mean this is significant this is going
on two months now and it's only getting
worse for any of the brands associated
with the with with the cult yeah and
this is extremely encouraging to see you
mentioned a moment ago the fact that the
Bud Light boycotts went very well
significant damage was caused to a
company which was pushing something
horrible I remember when the target
boycotts began one thing I said was we
need to be very careful about ensuring
that we stick to the Target boycott
because this is going to determine
whether the Bud Light boycott was a
fluke
or whether conservatives have them as a
market are going to retain this power
well yeah they've got to be if the thing
is if we jump out there too quick and we
start trying to boycott everything yeah
real quick we're none of them will be
successful agree and we will start
losing our Effectiveness which is back
to what I was saying we have to cause
permanent economic harm to a large
company and Bud Light is so far been
that company and it looks like their
brand man
I've never seen a brand destroyed so
quickly and so succinctly ever they're
not going to be able to just come back
and all of a sudden you know they've put
out bottles with camouflage bottles they
just put out a Harley-Davidson special
edition bottle oh my God like it's just
harming Harley-Davidson is not bringing
their brand back and so again if we
stick to it I don't know how long a
Target
boycott will last
uh that it's it's it's harder for a lot
of people to do without it's not about
the boycott though that's that's the
important thing no I get what you're
saying on the other side of it but just
saying as to what what conservatives
will actually stick through and holding
the feet to their fire economically I
don't think conservatives actually
boycott a Target
I think regular people got pissed yeah
so I see two things happening Bud Light
was a boycott it was high profile
individuals then what this guy points on
the New York Mega article is that people
boycott so the media picks it up so the
news spread so more people boycott with
Target I think
something was happening before the news
even broke
we started seeing these videos pop up of
people complaining then then news broke
of Target saying they had confrontations
well hold on there was not enough time
to have elapsed in when people on
Twitter saw videos and when
confrontations could have happened yeah
I think regular people walked into
Target and went yo WTF I got my kids
with me I don't want them seeing this
stuff then they filmed videos then
Target responded what we're seeing now
with Target stock collapsing is
connected to Bud Light but it doesn't
matter what so here's the important
thing look
when uh the way I explained this last
week was that I knew this woke woman and
she Inherited property from her family
in New York and she was talking about
marginalized people and all of that
stuff and I asked her if a black family
moved next to her her property in New
York would she sell and she went of
course
and I was like are you kidding I was
like that's racist I was like why would
you do that and she said because
property value goes down and I was like
are you kidding me it goes down because
people like you do this and she's like
yup and there's nothing I can do about
it so I'm not gonna be the one who gets
economically hurt by the system
what people need to understand is that
the biases I've talked about this before
this is this is systemic bias the market
responds to fear of the market yes and
we've now created that because of Bud
Light it does not matter what people do
going to Target all that matters is the
stock will go down yeah that means you
could do absolutely nothing and people
holding Target will lose money because
of the negative press causing them to
panic sell causing the price to go down
creating a Cascade effect I'm reminded
of this quote that's attributed to Mayor
M shell Roth's child who founded the
Rothschild banking Dynasty which was
like the precursor to the the world the
banking this liberal economic order
banking Dynasty is the Ross Childs they
said that he said give me control of a
nation's money and I care not who makes
its laws so when you talk about having
control of money it's not necessarily
who prints it that's not where the
control ends it's how you spend it and
when you get enough people to come
together to choose how to spend their
money and and how not to spend their
money you are more powerful than any
amount of lawmaking and this is it's
shown with this this A B inbev drop in
11 of their stock value and targets
dropping 11 I mean you can you can make
Bank runs that's the most powerful force
on Earth if you want to talk about like
you know I'm not advocating for that I
thought a lot about that over the last
15 years like wow I could just tell
everyone to pull their money out on a
certain day at a certain time but it's
like that almost feels like economic
terrorism you know but that amount of
power that you could to move the market
and control Earth I think Congress
commits economic terrorism on us every
single day yeah it's very a job I I you
know this phrase economic terrorism I
was just going to mention this because
you're absolutely correct that the
people have a tremendous power I mean
this is called the dollar democracy you
can choose where you spend your money
and companies are afraid of that that is
why they're trying to label what's
happening to Target a kind of economic
terrorism they're referring to us as
extremists for not wanting to shop there
anymore it's because they're scared I
think as long as you're not trying to
hurt people and destroy the system
there's no Terror involved you have no
responsibility or yeah uh to spend your
money anywhere the terror is the inverse
the terror is when antifa's like you
must support these things or else or
when they burn Target down like they did
like they did Target got burnt down by
BLM in a riot and then they issued a
statement saying we support BLM yeah
boycotting Target because they're
pushing the gross groomy lgbtq agenda
onto kids and Target was like well this
is completely unacceptable you have no
right to do that did you see it no
target said where's so sorry we're gonna
hide all this stuff in the back and then
whisper to the LGBT community saying
don't worry we got your back so well
they did kind of like what Bud Light did
we're hiding it in the back because
these conservatives are so dangerous
they're going to come hurt you and then
one thing that I like to point out that
a lot of people missed with the whole
Bud Light thing you know everyone
there's all this talk you hear
constantly that oh Bud Light they fired
their VP of marketing they didn't fire
anyone yeah I know exactly hey leave and
if you even read their statement as to
why she went on paid leave at the end of
the statement it you know I don't have
it in front of me right now I could pull
it up I guess it says something to the
fact of being concerned for the safety
of our employee almost implying she was
in so much Danger from conservatives by
being out in front they never disavowed
anything they did servers wanted to call
Victory or that you can't I want to jump
to the story from Newsweek ladies and
gentlemen the latest update in the sales
numbers coming through this morning at 7
A.M Bud Light sales dropped
29.5 in latest week 30
we round up we round up here 30 that is
massive anecdotally that is brutal dude
we were at a hotel over the weekend and
they had drink tickets from 537 free
drinks I was like great I'll get a I'll
get a beer I'll get something IPA
they're like the only free beer is Bud
Light did you notice
and so they know it's gonna go bad
eventually and so it's gonna be worth
literally zero to them so I mean
economic situation yeah becomes a cost
they have to remove it how long does
beer last it depends on the beer and the
bot even down to the cans
um it's again it depends on the beer in
the cans like I mean it's some people
say different times you can easily have
a beer for six months but you gotta keep
in mind some people say way longer I
wouldn't say but you got to keep in mind
those beers are on the Shelf you know
they came and got it and put it put it
on the shelf on Thursday right that beer
was not canned with a company like Bud
Light That was not canned you know the
week prior this is a massive process
with these things so they've been
traveling around the country depending
on where they're at does it get better
like over time like wine uh no
definitely not yeah it's more bitter
more like probably right if fly I don't
know that I would say rancid I haven't
tried a super old beer so I can't really
say but I do know it goes bad thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time